when firms become dominant they can
become too big to care that's FTC chair
Lena Khan at the Wall Street Journal CEO
Council she's answering a question about
the Taylor Swift Ticketmaster Fiasco a
situation that's renewed calls to undo
its decade-old merger with Live Nation
which has plagued Washington DC and the
music industry for years tickets to
Swiss first tour in five years went on
sale to verified fans and then to
Capital One card holders but in both
cases a glitchy system kept fans from
securing tickets once they got into the
system they'd click on tickets that
would disappear they'd get kicked out
they'd get error messages which prompted
Furious fans to take to the internet
what do you mean something went wrong
I'm not doing this today Ticketmaster
and lawmakers to call for scrutiny
there's no other choice that's why we
are pushing the justice department to
look at this before tickets could open
to the public Ticketmaster canceled the
sale
so how did Ticketmaster reach the point
where lawmakers and fans are calling for
scrutiny fan testimonies Congressional
hearings as well as court documents to
tell the story
now Taylor Swift fans are suing
Ticketmaster over claims that the
ticketing giant violated antitrust laws
and some lawmakers are even calling it a
monopoly to understand why we have to go
back the timeline starts here in 2009
when two of the largest companies in a
live event space sought to join together
will the combined company be tempted to
divert tickets to the resale Market at
inflated prices because there are now no
competitors to keep this behavior in
check Live Nation CEO Michael rapino and
then CEO of Ticketmaster Irving azoff
pled their case in front of the
Judiciary subcommittee on antitrust it
was 2009 so this is right in the thick
of the financial crisis concert
promotions are really really tough
margin business whereas ticketing on the
other hand is a very high margin
business this financial need was one of
the main talking points of the time for
why the two required a merger I have two
choices I can hope the economy gets
better or I can stick a more proactive
approach to protect our employees reward
our shareholders and better service
artists and fans of course the committee
also heard the opposing case antitrust
law attorney David a Balto as well as
some music promoters each testified
against the merger from a
straightforward horizontal concern this
merger is anti-competitive the fear was
that this would create this Behemoth
that would kind of have a Stranglehold
on the music business that's because
Ticketmaster was already the dominant
ticketing provider a Live Nation was the
largest promoter of live shows blending
the two would mean the company would
have a hand and pocketbook in nearly
every step of the live event business
when you have that type of integration
it can create certain types of conflicts
of interest at the time there was a
concern that Ticketmaster might use its
its position to tie those things
together and to say well in order to
have access to this venue you actually
have to use our ticketing site the
Department of Justice ultimately allowed
the merger after coming to an agreement
with the companies through what is known
as a consent decree under this
settlement it says that Live Nation is
not allowed to to strong arm venues into
using Ticketmaster but almost 10 years
later reports broke that the doj Was
preparing legal action for that very
reason according to this report it
believes it violated a merger settlement
by trying to coerce concert venues into
using Ticketmaster without Live Nation
admitting any
resettlement with
viewed it as sort of a slap on the wrist
then as the Biden Administration took
office lawmakers like U.S representative
Bill pasqurell voiced hope for stricter
antitrust laws in a letter to the admin
Pascal along with several other
Democrats said the evidence of strangled
competition is overwhelming and called
on the admin to revisit the merger we've
seen these agencies the doj and the FDC
really be encouraged to take a more
critical eye toward these big mergers as
part of a broader effort President Biden
signed an executive order last year
aimed at promoting competition in the
American economy let me be very clear
capitalism without competition isn't
capitalism it's exploitation but that
fall as Live Events began revitalizing
from the covid-19 hall issues with
Ticketmaster's site continued to mount
similar problems to Swift's era's tour
happened last year with the BTS concert
and Olivia Rodriguez too then in
December this year Ticketmaster
apologized again this time for a Bad
Bunny ticket Fiasco in Mexico City
oh
in the current live event Market it's
not uncommon for a ticketing site to get
overwhelmed with high volume but this
reached an entirely new scale with
Taylor Swift for the first day of
pre-sales they sold over 2 million
tickets to her show which is the most
tickets sold for any single artist in a
single day in Ticketmaster history
Ticketmaster sold tickets to all but
five of her 52 stadium shows the ones at
the State Farm stadium and the at T
Stadium were sold through sea geek
that's because of a business practice
known as exclusive ticketing contracts
in that case Ticketmaster goes to venues
and inks an exclusive deal which means
anything that comes through this Stadium
or arena is going to be
sold through Ticketmaster in an
interview with CNBC Liberty CEO and Live
Nation chairman Greg Murphy credited the
company's Stellar services for its
market share our competitor who is the
promoter for Taylor Swift chose to use
us because we are the in reality the
largest and most effective ticket seller
in the world even our competitors want
to come on our platform to which Taylor
Swift's promoter AEG rebuted and they
said no we actually didn't have a choice
she's the biggest artist in the world
she's going to tour in stadiums and
those stadiums are locked up in
exclusive contracts with Ticketmaster
Live Nation has said it didn't engage in
behavior that warranted litigation the
company added that the ticketing
industry is more competitive than ever
it's pointed to some of the deals that
it's lost in venues to competing
services and it says that it continues
to innovate and make its technology
better the justice department declined
to comment
while calls billed for the doj to undo
the deal many industry experts wonder if
reversing the merge would solve the
issue Ticketmaster would still be the
dominant player in the ticketing
industry it would still control some 70
to 80 percent of the market and it would
still have these exclusive ticketing
contracts with the venues but undoing
the merge isn't the only option at the
doj's disposal they can also do
investigations into whether current
business practices are unlawful under
separate laws the legal actions taken
against Ticketmaster and Live Nation are
pending in the meantime Taylor Swift
fans are Scavenging resale sites still
hoping to secure tickets
foreign